yes popping off yeah you wouldn't know
it's not like something you were just a
little just a little back in until small
mousy little [ __ ] boy just a little
tiny oh oh you're building the table
over there oh yeah building a little
sequel table over there a little MongoDB
even a little little you little database
slice a little a little data scientist
your [ __ ] little data scientist aren't
you
you love dropping tables don't you when
you're not supposed to cute little back
in [ __ ] boy over there just coding away
Oh ones and zeroes you know props to him
for making a back-end developer sound
like it's [ __ ] moving boxes yeah
exactly that had to have been the most
insulting part about that whole video
like even even the part where he he
called me not a real man yeah that was
whatever that part I was like pretty
like I was like a little bit insulted by
but like when he when he said a little
back-end developer I was like oh you
[ __ ] dude you [ __ ] [ __ ] for he'll
[ __ ] [ __ ] who are you you're a
goddamn high school dropout isn't he
yeah yeah I had to study for [ __ ]
eight goddamn years to have that career
yeah work my ass off for that [ __ ] it's
a great [ __ ] career technically it
was a senior iOS developer not the same
as the back-end developer also what I
want to do let's let's get to things
right first of all these try to downplay
fullscreen it's just some creator
network no [ __ ] it's like a
three armed like it's a massive
corporation is owned by [ __ ] Warner
Brothers dude it was sold to 18t which
is then passed off to Warner Brothers
okay that's one
to fullscreen like I didn't even know
this until i worked there their whole
like corporate sales branch and focus
lock up anyway we want to get into then
the other thing i want to get into is
breath it's back in developers that gave
your dumb ass a platform to be somebody
software engineers who
built your whole said yeah I know you're
gonna [ __ ] on software engineers they
gave you the thing that makes you you so
true you wouldn't be any weird beam
you'd be your foot you'd just be some
annoying dude in [ __ ] Ohio still if
the if like the internet wasn't as
powerful as it was you just be a dude
they're being annoying somewhere yeah if
ever you owe it to every software
engineer on the [ __ ] earth for who
you are Mulligan so true hmm so so
goddamn true
that was the funniest part to me you
just gonna [ __ ] on the the funny the
funniest part is just how god-awful that
whole video was yeah how do you how do
you [ __ ] something up like that that bad
I don't like and the guys the most are
the most like ironic part about the
whole thing is that he's like he's like
trying to give me a taste of my own
medicine by making the video like the
same style that we do yeah but like he's
refuting everything he's saying in the
video by doing that yeah how does he not
understand that yeah well how does he
not understand that like I'm gonna sit
down and cyberbully this dude about how
he's a cyber bully makes no [ __ ]
sense it's like now dude this removes
them all of your credibility because
you're doing what you're what you see
are telling people not to do in the
video oh I also like how he compared you
to his brother which I don't even have
to articulate as to why that's a what do
you mean What did he say
he's like he needs to face some backlash
so you know like my brother went through
a controversy I was like a nobody ever
died on our podcast son or video son I
love the way and I love the way that he
talked about it like it's just like a
like a thing but yeah it's just so he's
got to go through a couple of those yeah
you know a couple notches on your belt
that guys that you film once you get
through that stuff you're in the clear
or a better person no it's just like
you're in the no not even that it's just
like you're in the clear you just got to
do that you know the changes a person
has just got to go through it yeah you
know I'm saying you gotta like learn
pretend to learn whatever but then like
once you're through it you're good you
can keep [ __ ] you know burning cars
and like oh oh I I honestly alright I
think it's one of two things one is
he no [ __ ] clue who you were and Jeff
hit him up and then he goes Cody who
which it was probably the funniest part
of the whole thing that's when he was on
top this one he goes Cody who mm-hmm
then he sees you're talking [ __ ] and he
goes like his eyes get red but he didn't
really like process what any of what
you've said he's like almost almost
smoke this dude cuz like he'd know he's
seen heat back when [ __ ] we did keep
your dick fat did he wash it yes I
talked to some kids that lived in the
team tan house and then each partying
and ya know he knows he's seen all truth
no he definitely knows who we are
yeah or it definitely you but yeah so I
guess that Nicks is that it just doesn't
seem like he thought through any of what
he was gonna say and if he did that's
[ __ ] sad mm-hmm if that was him being
prepared wolf
it what I mean it couldn't have been I
don't think I don't think there was a
single sentence like a like a full
sentence in that whole video no like it
really no okay it that well I was like
chuckle and I was like holy [ __ ] this is
one of the situations where you were
like alright form an opinion you can't
form an opinion in 17 minutes I'm will
be their brains I animosity and you know
you know spreading negativity and the
youth some of the little more are so not
animosity and moss what's the present
form of animal and mosses and you know
it's negative and I don't actually
support the spreading of my thoughts and
thought processes and ideas that share
animosity I don't know the the whole
like it's just funny it's been a weird
[ __ ] week yeah I'm sure it's been a
bizarre week like just from going from
zero to like then going on this show
yeah ain't coming and talking about on
the podcast that's orders being like
that sucked
yeah and then what happened afterwards
yeah like we were like drinking Saturday
night and we're at Cabo Cantina and so I
had a margarita and then we
gone back home and just gonna go to bed
there's your sponsor know you had a
margarita and I I texted my sponsor yeah
three days sober Sam's response err he's
like good job dude it's fine
they dude it's fine you can have another
it's how we deal and then I get home and
I all of a sudden start getting tweets
of being like Jake posted a video Jake
posted a video huh what what yeah how am
I supposed to this vlog and I go on and
and it just so shocked to see like the
whole thing was about me like you know I
don't think he ever really does that no
saying yeah and so we watch it and I'm
like I don't want to watch I don't want
to watch this because I haven't seen it
footage yet I know it's gonna be [ __ ]
uncomfortable yeah and we turn it on and
start watching it's like this is this is
awesome yeah awesome the whole thing was
so entertaining seven minutes is like
you know saying yeah yeah and then yeah
and then it's just been it's just been
crazy [ __ ] like a bunch people I
follow or subscribe to did a video about
it
um just cool to see all like everyone
tweeting about it and everything and the
[ __ ] yesterday I gained 90,000 subs
just probably from like PewDiePie's
video and [ __ ] like that yeah so sick it
I mean like it yeah I mean it's just
like it's been cool like it's like
worked out pretty well for me but it's
like mmm I never thought I'd be in like
a drama yeah you know saying yeah yeah
totally
that said it's all the new patreon nurse
who came here just to hound us for
that's cringe it's it it's probably not
gonna happen
yeah this has already said this is it
right here yeah I mean the whole thing
was just goofy I just didn't seem like I
don't even in a way I don't even really
think he thought it would go the way it
did I think he thought he was just gonna
say that you know maybe Ethan or
somebody calls him a dummy and he just
he just wave it off and then it like
looks like I don't know it like he's the
only phrase that comes to mind is like
he's remarketing to like his existing
audience
right like yeah totally like he like is
he's done this type of [ __ ] before yeah
you know where he like he just he just
wants to put a little life in his
channel and so he's getting into it with
everybody you know but he'd probably
realize like I may boxing isn't
necessarily the way to go right I think
like you can't box everyone that is as a
opinion about it but um usually I think
I think that he got the text from Jeff
mm-hmm
he sees the drama going on right now and
he says oh this is perfect
like I can kind of capitalize off the
the whole internet people are really
tied up in this [ __ ] right now they want
to see drama so I'm gonna confront him
because it's something I've wanted to do
for a little bit yeah I'll make a video
about it and so that's as far as he
thought he did it and then I think what
happened is his editor put together that
video and then and then was like hey he
clearly doesn't [ __ ] upload the
videos to his channel and show like that
it's not him doing that it's it's
someone else right yeah that's why I
like the description is like his face
was so priceless like that wasn't Jay
Paul sitting down writing right right
whoever the [ __ ] is his editor or
something like that
who's ever probably sent him a cut and
he's like in his car so I'm shedding II
watch it yeah that's fine yeah go post
it yeah I can't imagine if he actually
sat down and watched that video that
he'd be like yeah this is like he was
just edited in such a way that like yeah
he would've been like okay find it a
little bit more like hateful clips that
to use in the thing like right calm
powder yeah that's the clip you're gonna
[ __ ] use me give one of minions it
doesn't make any sense yeah you really
think those things are hateful yeah
where is your [ __ ] yeah what do you
think hate is the cat's insane you must
you must be like every single every
single time you go to the comedy store
you must be sitting there [ __ ] angry
the whole time because like that's what
it is I'm not yeah you know I'm saying
yeah okay I wanted it like and this that
felt like just me stoking the fires
there's no point with I'll be really
funny I made a video I was like you know
I I kind of agree now and not only do I
agree I think there are many people who
are doing this that we need to discuss
but we can't go for it we need to go for
the big fish
okay so let's start with Netflix okay
first up the guys got bill burr okay he
has three videos on Netflix three video
that's talking about other people he
talks about the president he talks about
he stars about Hillary okay he makes fun
of her losing that's not nice okay she
put in a very good effort the that's not
funny that's not funny at all
is this the message we want to be
sending to people make fun of people who
put in presidential campaign effort he
says this is what I'm saying
yeah it's harvesting animosity exactly
yeah and it's the youth yeah are growing
up right and they're seeing this and so
all of a sudden now they're it's it's
it's almost in like it's harvesting like
negative thoughts and did I say
animosity next up on Netflix
it's got Joe Rogan I don't this guy he's
got two videos on here one of those kind
of old this one is new and I don't know
how you have this much hate in your
heart he uses the B word the F word they
don't even put the dolphin noise over
there just go through every comedy
special ever row the the the I mean the
best part is that when I say I mean I
hate minions the only person that likes
minions is my mom and then it clips back
and he goes he's just a ball of hatred I
know yeah making sure called says ball
of hatred
dude the that to me was like the editor
didn't want to sit through all your
videos yeah you say I'm not gonna
exactly yeah exactly gonna look at the
ones that say Jake Paul and try to I
think if anyone were to like review the
work yeah if there was just another
person that chained and watch that video
you would have been like to do a little
bit more like this is gonna like
backfire like do a little bit more I was
gonna take you can take clips out of
context and make me seem shitty like yes
gonna do it dude I was chuckling the
best one would have been the Skippy
video oh they look at it makes fun of
virgins that's people that's people's
right this one would have been [ __ ]
lily ponds video where I started off by
saying she sucks like that like I'm like
god she's
sass or some like that which I go back
and watch I'm like that's a little bit
harsh they could have taken that clip
yeah you know he's listening right okay
yeah next time we're gonna do the
follow-up yeah dude when I saw the
cameraman I was laughing because in my
mind I'm thinking all right Jake and his
brother they've been training boxing and
MMA this cameraman has got to be I'm
thinking of like they're these dudes
that had like a travel vlog channel that
used to come in a full screen all the
time and they'd walk in there like
carrying their read like they would vlog
with a read and they were like some like
almost like that production company buff
nerds like they were like kind of like
those dude it's like you know rugged
camera dudes I'm thinking like oh that's
the type of dude this cameraman is gonna
be because the way you described it to
me I'm thinking it's like Jake and a
goon and they're like yeah you [ __ ]
cyber bully I see him he's just a pissed
off we me I started [ __ ] dying laughs
yeah yeah yeah that doubt that's who was
stink-eye me the whole time yeah dude he
totally seized up in there
he thought he was totally afraid like he
totally like change his opinion I'm like
where son where did you do that what
kids dude the whole thing is just like
like I ought to be to be candid I think
the whole thing was sad yeah I watched
that whole thing I'm like this dude is
down bad while he's reaching reaching I
know and then for the next video to be
confronting Roseanne but even that I
watched that because I'm like did he do
it in the same stand it was like you
know he was gonna be in Lohan's music
video and all that and there's just like
a there's like a palpable desperation in
his voice like and I can't describe it
there's just something off like like
three months three four months ago
before like the desi boxing situation
like you see him and he'd be like really
animated like he's pumping he's
confident like yo what's up guys it's
Jay Paul it's everyday bro like he's got
that whole speech and he plan and then
now like between the video he did on you
and that little Zen video he's like he's
like
apologetic in the little damn video he
goes I'm okay my goals for this year are
of no drama
stop cyberbullying it's like he read a
ton of comments and is like okay I'm
gonna do whatever makes you guys happy
like you know I'm saying no I totally I
think it's like what happens when
there's like this they're just kind of
like well I don't know what that there's
no theme there's no like whatever like
they both had their shtick before rush
dick was daily vlogs mm-hmm
they both had their thing being maverick
Jake Paul ur dick Paul ur that's
everyday bro and that's what they repeat
and it's like I'm just gonna do this
every day there's a routine and we're
gonna grow this [ __ ] mm-hmm now it's
like what the [ __ ] is it now you know
they I think they just both are in this
like weird identity crisis were just
like what well castor I'm a I'm a I
still vlog but it's not every day bro
it's it's every third day yeah sometimes
it's not a vlog sometimes yeah yeah you
know I'm saying and so just like what
who am i anymore I don't know that and
like they're least Jake's audience for
cherski was like a lot younger yeah and
you know and and I don't know how much I
could say I don't want to name names but
somebody we work with has told us that
working and that demo is tough because
they age really quickly and it can even
be as matter like it can just take a
year or two and you'll lose like 20% of
your audience because like they that's
how fast kids like just evolved for like
yeah change yeah you know oh it could
take like just you know a few kids it
like a little bit older than them to be
like you like Jake Paul you're a [ __ ]
cornball no no no I don't I don't like
Jake yeah yeah that type of [ __ ] so yeah
I definitely think and you know Jake to
his credit as he tries to shield against
that right like with team ten like he's
got he's got a whole [ __ ] family
living in that mansion crazy yeah I just
learned that and uh you know team tends
all kids now mm-hmm but you know I felt
like teen ten was also kind of dependent
on his success you know I don't know I
think he's in a tough spot like for I
was that was my first reaction
well you told me that I'm like damn
Jake's coming for Cody he's out of [ __ ]
yeah like he's at a target they got no
one left yeah yeah cuz cuz Atlit I feel
like him that's the dream you know I'm
saying outside of [ __ ] even everybody
like commentaries out of YouTube is like
well I hope I hope he comes down here
and [ __ ] just spits on my channel a
little bit yeah that'd be that'd be
beautiful that's true that that's a good
point because before that he was above
that yeah everybody and their mom but I
think that's what it was
every everyone would always make a video
about him and he's our hunk of a [ __ ]
yeah and he showed that he gives a [ __ ]
and that was just like the armor falling
off yeah that's true I think that's
where he really [ __ ] up yeah
everyone's like oh you're a [ __ ]
actually yeah wow you went to the
haircut
show yeah and that's a really good point
it's a good way of looking at it just
you don't say yeah cuz it started that's
how I started to feel for me I'm like
wow you drove all that way and you said
you've stood down there acting crazy and
all that just to go in there like to
fumble your words bro what happened to
none of that was there yeah that bravado
none of that yeah so that's what it
means the same thing it's the same thing
he's trying to figure out what the [ __ ]
to do and so he's like okay maybe I got
it maybe I got a fight negativity maybe
that's the thing yep you know I'm not up
here anymore kind of back down on earth
so now I gotta like maybe maybe this is
gonna be my thing I'll fight negativity
and whatever okay I'll face these people
now yeah yeah it's like yeah yeah I mean
it's just is what I was saying about
James Charles in the last podcast like I
blogan I don't love Paul
Jake [ __ ] him whatever yeah I'm he's
he's a young dude and and he's figuring
himself out in front of millions of
people yeah that's got a that's why pays
to be all dude you already know we are
exactly pieces of [ __ ] Canadian pieces
of [ __ ] what will me
not trying to flex and I'm holding half
his bags I'm trying to flex not trying
to flex take your fish - no sir
right that's not a flex